so there is a renewed and re-energized Beto
or war running around out there.
He's running for the Democratic nomination
in 2020 it's not going super well Beto as
port polling two to 3% in his latest post.
Second debate polls.
His first debate performance was atrocious,
but Beto is on fire this week.
I told you earlier this week that Beto was
finally speaking sort of more from the heart.
He wasn't using these calculated talking points
and he was speaking earlier this week about
the El Paso shooting very clearly and very
precisely, drawing a connective, a line between
Donald Trump's rhetoric and the shooting and
now he straight up called Donald Trump a white
supremacist on live television.
Take a look at this clip.
Okay.
You've been very clear that you believe the
president is a racist.
Is the president a white supremacist?
He is.
He's also made that very clear.
He's dehumanized or sought to do dehumanize
those who do not look like or pray like the
majority here in this country.
He said, I wished we had more immigrants from
Nordic countries because those from Haiti
bring aids, those from Africa come from shithole
nations.
Um, he's been very clear about who he prefers
to be in this country and who he literally
wants to keep out with walls and cages and
militarization and torture and cruelty.
And again, we in El Paso had borne the brunt
of all of that, but we in El Paso are standing
up to all of that right now.
And I've never been more proud of this community
than I am at this moment.
I don't really know if Trump is a white supremacist.
He's certainly fomenting and coalescing and
encouraging white supremacy.
But this is a great new Beto.
I set it Monday and I'll repeat it today.
If this had been the better we'd been seeing
all along, he might be polling better than
two or 3%.
I mean, it's really a breath of fresh air
in a world riddled with calculated talking
points and hedging on everything.
And from what I understand, there are people
around Beto.
I don't know if official campaign people or
just people that he talks to who are cautioning
him about saying certain things.
So bluntly politicians are supposed to you
know, have caveats and speak in vague language
that failed Beto completely the calculated
milk toast bullet points have completely failed
him and left him in a losing position in this
primary, it's probably too late already to
actually help them recover but maybe not.
He has qualified for the third debate.
The tell it like it is version of Beto is
absolutely the way to go and in fact this
is the version of Beto that almost saw him
take out an incumbent Republican senator in
the Red State of Texas, Ted Cruz.
He ultimately did lose but not by much and
it was close because it was genuine.
Tell it like it is, say what's on your mind
Beto and it's really just kind of sad that
telling it like it is in normal speech.
Is this notable for a politician?
Beto was asked a question, he answered it
clearly with a yes or no.
He supported it with examples and you can
say, well, it's easier now for Beto to just
let it fly and to behave this way because
he no longer has anything to lose because
he's pulling 2% you may be right about what
has inspired the change.
Maybe it is that he feels like he has nothing
else to lose.
It could just be that he is genuinely affected
by what's been going on in El Paso because
that is where he's from, but it's a sad commentary
on the political environment either way, whatever
the reasons are.
I'm glad to see this Beto and by the way,
whatever you think about white supremacist
as a term for Donald Trump, corporate media
won't even call Trump a liar.
We've talked about this before.
Corporate media will say when Trump has strayed
from the facts, when Trump has not been accurate
in the things that he has said times the president
didn't tell the whole truth.
And from what I understand, there are legal
reasons why many corporate media outlets stopped
short of just straight up calling Donald Trump
a liar.
But it would really be great if it wasn't
so rare to just call things what they are.
And I'm actually, I'm not, you know, people
know that my politics are more in line with
Bernie's, uh, or with Elizabeth Warren's for
example.
Um, not necessarily Beto O'Rourke, but I hope
that this Beto continues.
I hope that this is the better that we see
in the September 12th or 12th and 13th debates.
I guess depending on how many people are left
in the race at that point in time because
this actually is a Beto that might inspire
rather than confuse and sort of just, uh,
make people wonder what is it that he even
really stands for.
It feels too calculated.
It feels to focus grouped in some way.
Let's hope that it continues.
And, uh, by the way, speaking of a politician,
just speaking from the heart and telling it
like it is, uh, I was able to watch more of
Bernie's appearance on the Joe Rogan experience
yesterday.
A bunch of people on my twitch stream yesterday
said, you really got to check it out.
It was really good.
And I know that.
So, so there's this like never ending battle,
not to go completely off script here proverbially.
Um, uh, but there's this never ending battle
about should the left appear on Joe Rogan's
show because he allows so many right-wing
talking points to be parroted uninterrupted
or should left this avoid Joe Rogan's show.
I think the answer is very clear.
Anybody who goes on Joe Rogan's program is
going to be giving an opera, given an opportunity
to sort of flesh out their ideas with only
mild resistance or pushback from Joe.
Like that's the format.
And he pushed back on things I said a little
bit when I was on his program back in June.
Um, and he pushed back a little bit with Bernie,
but what was fantastic about Bernie's appearance,
which was only I think like 50 or 67 minutes
long or something like that.
What was great about it is that Joe provided,
you could argue that it was not enough or
too much depending on your politics, but he
provided an amount of pushback to Bernie that
was enough of for Bernie to be able to come
right back with counterpoints.
That in that environment were very, very strong,
fantastic appearance for Bernie Sanders on
the program.
I don't know if it's you know enough to move
polling for Bernie, but it certainly enough
to generate donations for Bernie, which unfortunately
in the money in politics, status quo system
that we have makes a difference.
And I think it was completely worthwhile for
Bernie to do it.